I mean I believe in agency so I think
that if a woman is going to look after
her children living divorce that's
absolutely fine I also believe in your
right to speak your mind about it what I
don't understand
before the 1920s women could speak
openly at this idea that like women
couldn't talk the last 500 years there
have been women throughout the United
States
has been there have been women
throughout history that have read
written and been very influential in
society okay so this idea like women
could never do it what I don't
understand though is when it gets
spiteful okay because you put down a few
arguments that I think are perfectly
like you know they're kind of
Evangelical in their Christian but those
are your right to say it what I don't
understand is when it kind of seeps into
this sort of you call women fat you say
that they shouldn't have are they you
say that they look like you know I mean
the question is are they fat yes or no
the average American woman is 170 pounds
that's pounds that's objectively
overwhelmed I mean let's be honest we
now celebrate morbid obesity